just in case you're wondering uh was
that a mouse slip and H5 this is bizarre
this is a very rare brunch of the
Sicilian both players already showing
their aggressive intentions here Magnus
whenever he opens one E4 with white
whenever he goes into the open Sicilian
it means he's spoiling for a fight he
really backs himself feeling confident
farouza meanwhile just the fact he's
employing this opening with black kind
of inviting an attack uh shows that he's
also scrapping for a fight and I I think
that will sort of get a bit nearer to
the truth of the position I was going to
recommend this move because with the
move H5 from black it seems like Black's
light squares a little bit more weakened
there like G6 and uh this move is a
super aggressive move in this kind of
structure I really hope we see that
because that'll be the most aggressive
moves on the board and uh black will
wait for his counter chance and this
move is a bit close to my heart as well
because this is what I call the
dragadorf it's a mix between the dragon
opening and the night off so we're
getting some really funky stuff often
Magnus used to play this opening as
black as well very well respected
openings but if often combining openings
isn't the most consistent way to play
and Magnus now is not going to hesitate
surely he's going to Castle on the long
side there we go
um yeah it's going to be fire just in
the next few moves uh farusha is is
calculating at this moment wherever he
can play that so he has gone Queen C7 uh
there's there's so many little
transpositions it's a very rich rich
structure here especially not black
because you know and there we see B5
being played this last one is a very
good move I mean uh the ideal setup for
Black is to develop his last piece
feature it take the sting out of that
move I can't really see much else but if
black can get both those moves in Knight
B6 Bishop B7 he has Castle I think is
that right so that's that that seems
kind of that's a very gutsy move just to
show you Simon Knight V6 I'm gonna break
through I think I can play E5 if you
take me there would have been nasty
sacrifices yeah and if the queen moves
away anywhere then this would have been
Checkmate so farouza made the best idea
uh kind of made the best decision there
primarily thinking of getting rid of
that Bishop with Knight C5 and the
evaluation bar is like oh oh
good news but I mean why David why is it
so important to take a nap on of course
if it might be a really difficult move
but not for a player called Magnus
Carlsen uh there is like you said modern
chess is so concrete and he finds the
best move no surprises there yeah past
Generations would play me maybe on
Instinct on feel on pattern recognition
alone but here it's kind of very
specific and they have no Prejudice if
they see a move that looks strong even
if it kind of disobeys general
principles then they go for at least top
players and that's why they're so strong
and instantly he knows okay he has to
block in Black starts going Bishop watch
out big threat black is threatening
Bishop to H6 now the dark squared Bishop
would actually pin skewer the White
Queen to the king so I'm expecting
Magnus to run there we go the other
advice I always uh was told as a junior
if you Castle Queen side always take
your time out to shuffle your king
towards the corner it's always safe
there I think it was a good idea when
you go when you go Castle on the queen
side King B1 is just a move that you
need to throw in whereas sometimes even
when our opponent doesn't have a direct
threat put that King on B1 get out of
the C line get out of the bin but you
know what I did instead Tanya I grabbed
the pawn
[Laughter]
and it was wrong
there you go the black king is about to
come under some severe pressure yeah he
trades off this bishop first make sense
but are we going to be left with some
Knight versus Bishop position where you
can clearly see it's going to be a good
night versus bad Bishop including a
weakness on the d-line yeah I mean
Black's just in a lot of trouble here I
mean I I thought this is maybe the best
try and uh the one one thing I'd love to
do with black is just put the bishop on
E5 which is kind of a normal idea but
with this last move there's a made
another major hole and this hole in the
middle of the board uh fuja he did all
these moves natural looking moves
developing the Queen the bishop and the
queen side castling and then suddenly
he's dead lost with black
how does Magnus do this
I wish we knew it's like a magic potion
that he uh just has up his sleeve and
somehow sprinkles this magic magic dust
in the board and but uh it does look
beautiful right now and wow okay he goes
for it throwing pawns forward this is a
sacrifice but I think he's uh just
banking on all the open files that are
about to uh line up against that black
king it should be a decisive attack and
it's no surprise with such beautiful
coordination beautiful centralization uh
for white that something like this would
work now and
right on E6 I mean you would never want
to pick up that g football but you
probably don't have an option because
it's sort of choosing the Lesser evil
you pick that up that pawn is going to
fall but also the H lines open the queen
jumps into an attack you go Queen to F4
you're hitting the pawn on DC and the
reason it's not a sacrifice is because
you can't step away the F Pawn because
the Knight will come and deliver a check
uh just putting pieces on good healthy
squares and uh it's the pin well takes
Rook would lose the black queen and this
would end in Checkmate and okay this is
on the board and I guess farouza's may
be banking on the fact this queen can
move it will he try and trade off Queens
uh what's he gonna try and do sooner or
later it just feels deadly something's
happening along the H file through the
critical door points the winner of
division two gets 50 tour points as well
as ten thousand dollars so the fight is
on follow it on chest dojo's twitch
Channel but I think it's impossible to
leave this position that we have right
now we might even be seeing game over a
Checkmate coming in soon and black has
just not managed to get play going on
the queen side well white has exploded
the king side uh and all of that is
being played out Queen H3 Rook H4 on the
board how do you even defend that Bishop
okay the only way to do it pushes the
pawn but you're kind of making more
weaknesses on the king side do you go
Rook H5 here
there we go Knight G5 a big threat on
the board now
his last piece into the game it's always
nice when you get every single piece
attacking well not nice for alireza but
nice and Magnus and uh G4 scene forced
but even just Queen D3 here looks looks
strong uh in this position maybe King G6
holds on uh on this square and I
recommend them you want to go H3 don't
you oh all right okay no it's H3 um in
the last position I think oh in the
previous position maybe but I thought
that's what you're okay uh yeah yeah
well I don't know maybe wow nice some
some nonsense we might see this being
played out king G6 something did not
work at all but I mean you do have
tempting options first you could take
this Rook but your own Rook is trapped
okay whoa ferrous is going for it I was
going to say here maybe you take and at
the very end you can pin this black Rook
you are winning long term but um look at
what's happened on the board I wrote
this one off I said white is just
guaranteed a Checkmate but for Rouge is
calling magnus's bluff where is the
Finish
oh can we find it can we get there it's
like puzzle Rush right there's so many
tempting options you need the Knight to
add it to the attack against the black
king Magnus has given a check forcing
the black king back Simon and your idea
on the board H3 you got to explain this
to us why do you want to sacrifice this
one and how does it finish after G takes
H3
and okay he hasn't taken it but um the
black king is just so weak here and
Knight and queen they're the best
attackers when a knight and queen
coordinate they can often just cause so
much chaos on the board and one Pawn uh
for the two black Brooks so technically
level points but it's just about the
king safety and the fact that what is
still on the board
clearly favors Magnuson he's going to
start munching on pawns at the very very
minimum wet's King's still super safe
can slide to A2 if he wants and is he
going to start getting greedy now
Black's D6 Pawn is up for grabs uh you
can give a couple of checks as well
there we go and actually wait to deport
might become a second Queen uh the white
king is slightly more vulnerable or at
least slightly less comfortable but
first is Magnus to start checking yeah
unfortunately the open a line oh and
there's a check there the the open a
line can be closed off at the very least
by playing B3 B4 so I don't see the
danger for Magnus I'll be so
professional to put in B4 when the fire
is on one side of the board no I I just
be looking at Checkmate here not not
closing up that file and oh this is a
nice move yeah attacking the room
attacking the rook and I think the thing
I don't think Ali razor can be too too
upset here because he's uh
sometimes he moves the rug and also
notice how the queen if it would have
captured The Rook it was defending the
H1 Square so you didn't have time to
take on B3 because Rook H1 wasn't
Checkmate so everything just falls into
place in White's position in just five
seconds for alireza he makes a move
I might be seeing your move just
shutting down the play on The Queen side
that would be unfortunate let's say that
would be very patriotic I mean there's a
little again there's little tricks you
could go Queen D3 and D7 but um maybe
this is what Magnus is calculating but
does allow some checks if you play that
way so this is you know you have to be
careful and it has played this
um and D7 is the move you want to play
but Rook H1 King A2 take on B free check
King takes B3 and you're safe but it's a
little bit like I want to play B4 now
you know it's kind of like oh you know I
just want to keep it safe because you
just have to calculate quite carefully
here I think this is winning uh for
white but you know just Magnus taking a
couple of seconds to do that and I don't
think you know Ali Razer should be that
upset with this game because he got he
got a rotten opening right and he didn't
really get a chance I mean uh I don't
know where he should have uh played
differently maybe it was as simple as it
was just a very bad opening you know
I'll push back on that because that
seemed like the storyline between the
Fabi not the back game Fabi in that game
one that felt like solid opening prep
here just felt like he got outplayed it
wasn't a miniature it wasn't a result
just out of the opening but every move
his Advantage kept going increasing on
and on and I think it's really difficult
to lose game one in this way and to me I
was hoping for an Armageddon but with
the way we've just seen him out play
future I don't think we're getting that
he's got white in the next game so you
know don't don't let's not write him off
yet I mean I do think it was a bad
opening I think uh pushing the H Pawn to
squares and then being careless with the
King and then jumping with the Knight
not anticipating some captures was too
much for such a razor sharp position and
Magnus